Welcome back everyone it's Charlie huge news
Sony and Marvel just announced a brand-new
spider-woman spinoff of venom 2 and Spider-Man
3.
That's right were finally getting a female
spider person.
They also just announced the director for
their Spider-Man kraven solo movie to so I'll
explained what's going on with both of those
we know a little bit about those movies.
The Easter eggs and where it fits into the
continuity with the live-action spider verse
stuff is going on because of all the Tom Holland
venom crossover stuff is coming.
If you're new to the channel.
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
will do a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be subscriber and let me
know what you want them to do with spider
woman inside the larger spider verse I'll
start with the spider woman stuff first then
I'll talk about Kraven at the end of the video
will number these as we go along to stay organized
and talk about Easter eggs, but everyone Queue
up the explain or listen to this one last
time.
Starting with number five if you didn't see
the news Marvel Sony like I said just announced
that Olivia Wilde.
The actress will be directing their new secret
Spider-Man venom 2 spinoff movie Sony and
Marvel did not reveal with the official title
would be only that it would be a Marvel movie
originating from Sony inside the Marvel universe,
but all the legit trade publications and sites
that were reporting the news like deadline
variety Hollywood reporter.
The big sites said that the movie was going
to be spider woman, so it's a pretty safe
bet that that's what's going on than right
after the announcement was made Olivia Wilde
herself tweeted this spider emoji just confirming
the news like yes this is going to be a big
Spider-Man venom 2 spinoff Olivia Wilde most
of you will know from somewhere in the past
10 years she's done a bunch of stuff she was
in Tron Legacy she was on house for a long
time.
She's been in a billion movies, but the past
several years.
She's also been directing her own movies mostly
smaller in the movies, but she's been getting
a lot of hype.
So this is a big upgrade for her and I think
she's a great pic I think should be good fit
for the movie.
They already hired a writing team to do the story
and we know is gonna come out sometime between
2022 and 2023 sometime in the next three years,
but number four which version of spider woman
is this going to be because there are several
versions of spider woman in the comics.
How much will she cross over with the venom
movies in Tom Holland's Spider-Man from the
MCU in Italy are all asking now the next question
will be see Easter eggs for spider woman in
any of the upcoming Sony Marvel Spider-Man
movies like the Morbius movie venom 2 or Spider-Man
3 over in the MCU and where will her earth
be set will it be on venom's earth is gonna
be on the MCU earth or is a going to be in
some other universe of the spider verse and
forgetting into multi-verse territory during
marble phase 4 in all the Sony venom movies.
Most of the journalists that were talking
about the movie this morning were using Jessica
drew artwork because she's the main version
of spider woman from the comics.
When someone says the name spider woman usually
you think of her first, because she's the
original version of the character, but there
been a bunch of women to of use the spider
woman name talking about the Spider-Man into
the spider verse of it all.
You probably remember during the animated
spider verse movie Gwen Stacy called herself
spider woman one mostly in the comics, though
fans think of her is spider Gwen and then
they try to change her name in the comics
to go spider during spider get an last year
Sony revealed that they were developing full-blown
spinoff movies for some of the animated spider
verse characters like spider Gwen this live-action
spider woman movie could be what they were
referring to at the time, number three talk
about actresses.
They haven't said exactly who they're looking
at first, but I would be willing to bet they're
looking for someone younger, who's closer
to Tom Holland, Peter Parker age and because
the blip in Avengers endgame timeline.
He's about 18 during the events of Spider-Man
3.
They could do is go for slightly older actress,
but Hailee Steinfeld I think is a great example
would be a solid fit.
If they go younger, she played the animated
spider Gwen in the spider verse movie you
probably saw all the promos check she did
a fantastic job as an option out there in
the sense that everything is connected because
they also did talk about crossing over the
live-action Spider-Man movies with the animated
Spider-Man movies.
It was supposed to be a scene with Tom Holland
Spider-Man Andrew Garfield Spider-Man and
Toby Maguire's in the animated Spider-Man
into the spider verse movie, but Sony apparently
put the kibosh on that because they felt like
it was too soon to get that met up with the
movies so maybe we see something like that
during spider verse two it would just be hilarious
if Haley Steinfeld played both the animated
version in the live-action version as if it
were the same version of that spider person
that they want to go with Jessica drew though
she's a British characters of the podcast
a British actress someone like Daisy Ridley
would probably be who they go for first, but
let me know in the comments who you want to
play spider woman and which version of spider
woman do you want just to make another spider
verse multi-verse joke Tatiana Maslany was
great at playing a bunch of different British
versions of herself, so she also be a pretty
solid Jessica drew if they want to go little
bit older, number two.
How is this connected to Tom Holland Spider-Man
in the venom movies so there crossing over
Tom Holland with Tom Hardy's venom, technically,
that means MCU Spider-Man is can into the
spider verse or the venom verse, however you
want to think about it Sony's universe of
Spider-Man movies is a little complicated
because the Marvel movies and Kevin foggy
don't seem like they want to acknowledge a
lot of what's going on in Sony's movies, but
because of all the Michael Keaton sinister
six Easter eggs technically MCU is now tangentially
connected to the venom movies.
The whole point in doing that is to eventually
work up from Spider-Man versus venom 2 a live-action
Spider-Man into the spider verse movie and
sinister six any Pascal was hyping up there
sinister six plans, but she was also saying
that Sony was planning on doing a live-action
spider verse at some point it will be like
Sony's version of Avengers infinity war and
Avengers endgame they would have to take a
little bit longer to build up to something
that big so because Sony is the one releasing
the spider woman movie is more likely that
she's going to be set on venom's earth and
should be closer to the venom movie plot like
venom 2 right now.
There's rumors about the Morbius movie another
venom spinoff.
This is a during that they're starting to
set up the idea of OsCorp.
inside the Sony Spider-Man movies and eventually
they can start tying together all the different
Spider-Man venom spinoffs with some shares
story elements through Norman Osborne and
OsCorp. it's not a new idea that probably
sounds familiar, because that's exactly what
they tried to do in Andrew Garfield's amazing
Spider-Man movies or least a version of that,
but they went way too fast trying to get to
that big sinister six crossover this time.
It just seems like Sony and Marvel are taking
their time with the Easter eggs going way
slower, which I think is the smarter route,
but number one talking about live-action spider
verse in the new Backstory's for the characters
in the universe.
The original Jessica drew spider woman is
origin story is actually connected to the
high evolutionary if you can believe in the
sections of Easter eggs for him in the Marvel
phase 3 movies, particularly guardians of
the galaxy and there's been rumors that they
might try to use him is a Marvel phase for
villain or Marvel phase 5 like guardians of
the galaxy three.
He might be the person who helped create rocket,
but in the comics.
The original version of Jessica drew suffers.
Radiation poisoning and her father experiments
on her with spiders blood to try and savor
they wrecked con that later in the comics
and then just said that she was bombarded
with DNA from a bunch of spiders while she
was in her mother's womb and that's what gave
her her powers spider Gwen's back story is
a lot closer to classic Peter Parker's origin
story, she was just bit by a radioactive spider,
but on her earth of the multi-verse the spider
verse her version of Peter Parker actually
became a version of the lizard and they did
that hold back story on the animated spider
verse movie that was what she was referring
to when she was talking about losing her friend
this past trauma is that her version of Peter
Parker was her friend and he wound up dying.
She wasn't able to save him.
That's what she was afraid to make new friends
but if she wants them showing up in someone
else's movie first like cameo scene like Spider-Man
in Civil War.
Then going on to his solo movie.
It would probably be one of the Sony venom
spinoffs first like a post credit scene or
references to Gwen Stacy the movie still 2
to 3 years away from coming out though, so
don't expect to see her for a long time in
terms of the Kraven movie stuff is still very
early stages we probably won't see that movie
for a couple years but I worry that a bunch
of Spider-Man 3 videos about how it seems
like there can introduce Kraven during that
movie is a new sinister six villain and then
thinking even bigger the live-action spider
verse movies.
That's what I mean when I say that Sony is
working up to their own version of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame giant big
multi-verse spanning crossover story that's
their live-action spider verse, and just in
terms of Tom Holland crossing over in the
other movies Sony has been talking about putting
Spider-Man in some of their other spinoff
movies besides the venom movies, but no idea
how they would accomplish that.
If you would just be in the background like
you have in the Morbius trailer with the Spider-Man
costume or if he be Tom Holland or for just
be an actor in a Spider-Man costume pretending
to be Tom Holland's Peter Parker there's a
lot of ways you can put a Spider-Man in a
movie without having to be Tom Holland Spider-Man,
but everyone let me know in the comments.
What you most hyped up about of course I'll
do more videos about all the Spider-Man spider
verse movies, we get more details of the shooting
Spider-Man 3 really soon and will probably
get that first big venom 2 trailer later this
year, everyone click here for my video on
the Spider-Man 3 movie title and click here
for that big trailer for DC fandom this weekend
and all the other big DC movie trailer thank
you so much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!